it's so fluffy oh my god hey guys I'm
Brenda I'm a tasted producer and today
we will be comparing Americans vs.
Japanese cheesecakes now I'll be taking
care of the classic creamy cheesecake
that you guys all know really well and
I'm Alvin and I'll be making the jiggly
Japanese cheesecake because I think it's
such a unique twist on cheesecake that
you've probably seen online and it's so
cool I'm gonna show you exactly how it's
done
okay let's start there's American
cheesecake so to make the base you get
your graham crackers and you smash until
they turn into this
the reason why I began with a crust is
that it has to be baked twice once by
itself and then with the Cheesecake mix
so while this is baking you can just go
ahead and get started with your
cheesecake mix I'm not throwing all my
ingredients at once what I'm actually
doing it's starting with the sugar and
the cream cheese I also have all my
ingredients at room temperature
all of this will make it easier to avoid
lumps and will help me combine
everything perfectly let's go back in
time to this recipe album film before
which happens to be the one that
inspired my recipe look at the way he
comes in the texture that it appears to
have it's just beautiful
[Music]
let's cook this Japanese cheesecake so
the process is very different than a
traditional cheesecake this starts with
making a liquid cheesecake mixture of
cream cheese milk butter and sugar and
once that gets all nice and smooth that
gets folded into egg yolks and that
becomes this sort of like creamy liquid
ish kind of batter and that's sort of
your cheesecake base when I went to
Japan to work with the tasty Japan team
we had our eyes set on this jiggly
cheesecake that had been like a viral
trend around there for a really long
time just as amazing as it look it's a
very light fluffy soft cheesecake that's
very Airy it's a good cloud so it's like
almost you're making a meringue and then
you sort of fold the meringue back into
that cheesecake batter the funny thing
is that you could eat the entire
cheesecake because 80% of this is air
when we're in Japan it was not uncommon
to see someone buying a whole cheesecake
for themselves and finishing it on their
walk to work you need to bacon in a
water bath so what that does creates
like a nice steam barrier around the
cake so the cake will never get too hot
because the water will take excess heat
away from it this is one of my favorite
parts Alvin because you're pretty much
unveiling this mythical creature if it
looks super impressive you know it's
gonna be very fluffy
you know those tempur-pedic commercials
this was like memory foam for my hands
[Music]
let's face it all right let's pick right
here it's creamy and knelt it's not too
dense your cheesecake at least in my
opinion in terms of texture is superb
this thing is super fluffy
which one's your winner and why will
probably be the Japanese one when I want
something in a dessert I want something
that isn't too heavy so I can take more
than one bite I'm gonna go for the
Japanese version yes this is easier to
make but it seems a little more
adventurous to go for this one and the
texture the fluffiness and jiggling it's
just like ah this is a taste test one
out of three said that it would go for
your cheeks
I asked be born Instagram right there
69% on yours
31% on this one so there you go round
the internet have spoken Brenda that's
raw egg it's still delicious okay
[Music]